[Music]  fireworks seem to be flying between  Kendall Jenner and Ben Simmons over the  July 4th holiday Khloe Kardashian threw  her annual Independence Day pool party  where the new mom shared a snap of a  bikini-clad Kendall cuddling up to her  rumoured NBA pro beau just a day before  Kendall and bin were spotted packing on  the PDA poolside and I witnessed help ET  the pair enjoyed a romantic day out at  the Waldorf Astoria in Beverly Hills  cozying up together in a hot tub and  sipping on margaritas with a friend in  their own private Cabana I tried to  think as private as I can and insider  ads quote they snuggled up and looked  happy together  [Music]